est ce que vous êtes choqué quand un
groupe de rap prend comme non nique ta
main ou basta soeur
non parce que je suis habitué à entendre
les ministres s'expriment et lesieu
charasse madame cresson
d'accord avoir un petit sujet sont nique
ta mère je veux dire si c'est de l'info
ou de l'intox
la révolte est parti d'ici au milieu des
pins et des cigales dans les quartiers
nord de marseille
la cité de la savine le fief des bts bts
un nom devenu lourd à porter bts ben
comme ça ça ne me plaisait je lui dis
moi je baisse ma soeur et toi tu baises
ma soeur et de nos bts est arrivé voilà
simplement un thème nous aurons pris
avec ça peut lui se sont pris au sérieux
avec ça et se sont envolés et oui avec
un clip un 33 tours et le soutien
inconditionnel de jack lang
ntm ou si vous préférez nique ta mère a
bien décollé mais bts les traîne en
justice pour avoir plagié l'idée du
titre vestas heures ou niktamère il n'y
voit pas de différence absurde
rétorquent les accusés vous voulez
trouver un nom déjà fou bien français et
puis un peu provocateur alors voir anita
mais rien n'est jamais dans notre esprit
et voilà ces sorties et mtn n'ont fait
que reprendre l'idée d'un nom injurieux
et volontairement provocateur mais ce
n'est qu'une idée c'est du domaine
public tout le monde peut avoir la même
idée
en outre le nom retenu est suffisamment
différent pour qu'il n'y ait pas risque
de confusion et donc pour qu'il y ait
préjudice les pas de préjudice ce n'est
pas l'avis des bts et deux en avants ntm
le groupe marseillais n'est pas encore
connue mais protège déjà très bien son
image car celle des parisiens et bien
peu recommandable bts refuse toute
assimilation possible et ils ont fait
des détails avec des gros mots avec des
nids ta mère alors que nous au départ
les prix s'ajustent ironiquement juste
pour entre nous voilà
mais cris n'est pas bien encore une très
bonne pas ils ont affaire à
l'exploitation honteuse de l'idée que
sous tend ce genre d'humour par le le
groupe e nique ta mère tu ce qu'ils ont
raison de ne pas accepter parce que
c'est inadmissible et qu' ils sont
assimilés à une bande de de wendel
sociaux sont ils ne souhaitent un
provocateur à succès ne serait donc que
de viltain jr le tribunal de paris
rendra son jugement le 15 octobre
prochain
en attendant les intéressés se voit déjà
vainqueur quelle que soit l'issue de la
bataille
ces dames hier à reims ou sa religion ou
son fourreau puissant tir va même pas
que les sabres là le processus passera
dans le passé si ça ça a lieu général
santander publicité info ou intox
josé côte à l'oreille
d'accord je vais être dur le soin de
répondre ce que si c'est dur c'est dire
c'est très dur
je pense que c'est l'info que je pense
que j'ai là pour bientôt
parce que c'est
ça se passe souvent les prises de bouche
le business tu connais je pense que
c'est l'info je mens je pense que ça va
et toi madonna je tire un peu la même
chose nous dit montrant médine il faut
dire attendez que je réfléchisse comme
si j'étais encore un côté de la chanson
pour exiger à un peu lente
ouais la chanson assez
et bien pour aller encore dans le bas de
la fourchette de la foi aussi donc tous
les trois de l'info parce que je peux le
révéler maintenant pour jacques vergès
aussi c'est de l'info alors nous sommes
suspendus aux lèvres de notre ami
philippe guérin philips est à toi
il est content
ah oui mais moi aussi je suis content
filet on les a bien eus vas-y suis
heureux je suis plus heureux que tous
les autres samedi soir de ma vie parce
que évidemment c'était de l'intox pour
nos critiques faisant un commentaire à
nous faire sur cette affaire oui thierry
évidemment que c'était faux parce que
comment veux tu que ce soit vrai étant
donné qu'on a eu un mal fou à trouver un
jeune marseillais qui accepte de dire
nique ta mère
il semblerait qu'à marseille ce soit dix
fois plus injurieux qu'à paris à propos
d'un joueur des amis d'une chaîne
concurrente m'ont proposé de participer
aux groupes nt à nyc thierry ardisson je
tiens à vous rassurer tout de suite j'ai
refusé catégoriquement voiture est alors
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu